yeah you went to welcome to this video
yeah I am too late like it's Martin
Zoolander
yeah he really likes to play chess our
last five days ago today he played their
grand opening opening the rancor opened
with one of the strongest open
tournaments and after all these games he
wants to play him glitz in the evening
that's tough okay 8:30 precise water
keep forgetting those things now Bishop
d6 looks difficult to claim let's try to
play Bishop f4 now to make the rook look
a bit stupid
well it seems okay
since it seems okay
so easy to say what like should do now
we should therefore looks annoying
yeah I was thinking that this might be
the move but probably also not the happy
about it visually voice I prevented but
it's very slow
[Music]
yeah Bishop e7 probably and now I can
try this
efore Bishop f4 stuff winter quite a
number of tempie down but I don't know
it's really netting all that much in the
end maybe just start with this move
so I can do a folder should have fallen
out of it
let's wait how black is going to set
this up really not sure what to blare
back here what the best piece placement
is for black interesting
yeah I think I'm going to do it him the
set up and our 96 accessable come in
[Music]
look see 695 sir quite is quite annoying
for the seeker he said I don't see it in
97-minute wins the exchange that wins
the exchange
okay look see Sam huh my knight is
trapped when I was a stupid stupid idea
okay so I have to go back but the guy at
least and now his pieces look a little
bit awkward at least some went back so
if I go deform is player c4
unfortunately
[Music]
okay not ideal that how to play around
on to this piece how to ignore it
there was Jupiter yet except week c7 and
my night is trapped at the end and I was
stupid okay anyway maybe this is not so
bad okay so if I take now is going to
get the square which is not great takes
takes D for each for is hanging so you
bring this to see father and very tough
tough position maneuvering for little
things yeah
this is also having some drawbacks
you can define an f5 quite a bit that's
just for scam yeah I like this position
I think I'm okay here I mean okay
meaning a little bit better
[Music]
you
and I'm threatening to take on be 4026
okay so here if I take it there is a p8
so I'm going 45 and maybe I should click
push a page 3 instead probably was
interesting and now would have been
interesting strand 434 I should have
taken the other one should have taken
yellow
[Music]
time warning cannot take check and
visual f5 check that's probably equal
now he's got f6 I don't know why I did
that
check or this one
right strongly and it's no problem at
all
check I have this move check check
stalemate Jeff that was probably a
relatively quick draw I don't know if
there was anything else maybe little
things but nothing Jerry um I don't
think there was something substantial
missed by both of us okay I mean I
missed something in the line there where
I felt I'm fine but till three doesn't
really make any sense yeah I was really
thinking I can do this
after rook c7 of course my knight is
trapped here so I can't have to go back
[Music]
probably this is okay the engine likes
like after 96 maybe we have two nothing
super great but it was probably better
than the gainer
now taking we should be three maybe five
I felt was helpful for me and now I
should have taken played 85 now that
makes sense him it's always it's not
much here I probably should have thought
for a moment I played this reasonably
quickly there is also Bishop age 397 I
didn't look at but make sense Isaac
things this is also interesting
I have five okay it looks powerful okay
in the way it was played we're probably
just having a completely equal
positional I made one mistake
actually I wanted to the sword yeah yeah
I went down maybe I should play this one
so that I have Luke c8 here right
central slow below
[Music]
okay let's just just the draw cannot do
much them okay guys thanks for watching